our generation of Americans by the
people of all nations not only that we
ended one more but that we prevented
future Wars we have unlocked the doors
that for a quarter of a century stood
between the United States and the
People's Republic of China we must know
ensure those policies of that the ways
order of the world's people will be
continued to the People's Republic I
have asked Henry Kissinger as Secretary
of State to stay on and to be the
Secretary of State under the new
administration I've known Henry
Kissinger for a great many years I knew
at male McMillan's round of its own
freeway
yes I'm certainly glad you're home
[Music]
you